مرتبطا بالمتابعه القضائيه تماما كارتباطه
بالترشح لمنصب الرئيس المتابعات القضائيه
المختلفه التي تلاحق الرجل اثار التساؤلات
حقيقيه حول مدى قدرته على اكمال مشوار
التنافس على كرسي الرئاسه على الصعيد
القانوني لا يزال ترشح ترامب جائزا
فالدستور الامريكي لا يمنع ترشح اي شخص
مدان او لديه سجل اجرامي من الترشح
للرئاسه طالما انه مستوفر للشروط الثلاثه
وهي ان يكون من مواليد الولايات المتحده
وان لا يقل عمره عن 35 عاما وان يقوم او
ان اقام في الولايات المتحده لمده اربعه
عشر عاما متواصله على الاقل
سياسيا قد يكون من الصعب على المرشح
المتهم الذي قد يصبح مدانا ان يفوز باصوات
الناخبين لكن وضع ترامب يختلف نسبيا حيث
انه يحظى بقاعده جماهيريه واسعه كما انه
كسب تعاطف فئات من الجماهير من خلال تصوير
نفسه كضحيه لمؤامرات سياسيه المفارقه لان
انتخاب اي مرشح كرئيس لا يلغي التهم
المرفوعه ضدها علما ان الدستور يعطيه
كرئيس حق منح العفو الرئاسي لمتهمين اخرين
ورغم ان الدستور يسمح للرئيس بممارسه
مهامه من زنزانته الا ان الامر لم يحدث من
قبل ما قد يدخل البلاد في ازمه دستوريه
يعرف تهم الموجهه اليه في قضيه الملفات
السريه ممثلون لدعاء كشفوا على لائحه
اتهام بحق ترامب شملت 37 تهمه منها تعريض
بعض الاسرار الامنيه الاكثر حساسيه في
البلاد للخطر معلومات مرتبطه بملفات عديده
كالاسلحه النوويه الامريكيه واقمار التجسس
الصناعيه لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات